foreign
[Music]
you think your wife can hear you
no
white ball
Maybe I'm Wrong
to die
maybe not goodbye to you my trusted
friend
a new day is Dawning
new ideas no wounds
New Management we've been
since we
who is this
challenge him to single combat with a
loose it's a way out
I don't sit at the table your family
does please pray for me
[Music]
man has to look his best when it's time
to get married
or buried I'm going to need a gun
goodbye my friend
[Music]
if you win
the table will honor its word
we'll have your freedom
under the old laws only one can survive
failure to meet at sunrise
for result in execution
Last Words Winston just have fun out
there
I want you to find your peace but the
good death only comes after good life
you and I left a good life behind a long
time ago my friend
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
stand down I'm not the one to fear Pride
there is a Darkness coming
okay
it was all a dream
whoever I'm not driving
away
of all the threats
from both your past
and future
you've never faced anything like this
let them come
and if you don't know
[Music]
[Music]
I used to ask myself a lot of questions
Scott you're at ex-con
how are you an Avenger that doesn't make
sense but everywhere I go people tell me
the same thing thank you Spiderman
people still need help that that's why
we made this
like a satellite for deep space but
Quanah wait wait a minute you're sending
a signal down to the quantum Realm
turn it off
now
[Music]
where
Army
[Music]
it's a secret Universe beneath ours
so afraid of it
there's something I never told you
[Music]
Fox
it isn't what you think
my future
[Music]
I can get you home
and give you more time
if you help me
so
What's it gonna be
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is our chance
control the truth
the concepts of right and wrong for
everyone for centuries to come
you're fighting to save an ideal that
doesn't exist
never did
you need to pick a side
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
and when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
you need to unleash the greatest evil
the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need
it's a fighting chance we're gonna need
strength you got this right I know you
don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
the warned
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
sit exactly that you bring to this I'm a
planner I make plans you've already made
the plant so the existing plan fails I
make a new plan so you make plans that
fail no he also plays the loot not
relevant
[Music]
all right that's the car
oh my God okay
not sure if you know who I am but I'm
about to rule the world
wow
yay but there's one problem there's a
human has a mustache just like you
do you think I know every human being
with a mustache wearing an identical
outfit with a hat with the letter of his
first name on it because I don't
Bowser is coming
together we
are going to stop that monster how look
at us we're horrible oh I got this no
parabola
get it out get it up get it off
huge Universe out there
there's a lot of galaxies
they're all counting on us
yeah sure
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
and I miss waking up every morning
wondering what wonderful Adventure the
new day will bring to us
those days have come and gone Perhaps
Perhaps not
[Music]
I don't believe in magic
many times in my life
I've seen things
things I can't explain
come to believe it's not so much what
you believe
hard to believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
who is this man I'm her Godfather
get back
we were gone for quite a while
no matter what happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians
hello we come in peace
come on Drax seriously dude no don't I
don't know
don't forget
where we came from
we have been running
our whole lives
I'm done running
[Applause]
[Applause]
we'll all fly away together
one last time yeah beautiful
are
good
[Music]
[Applause]
and we'll kill anyone who gets in our
way no not kill anyone kill a few people
kill no people kill one guy one stupid
guy who no one loves now you're just
making it sad
hahaha
guys
thank you
location unknown
Charter 373
Commander Mills my ship was hit by an
undocumented asteroid
[Music]
transporting 35 passengers
[Music]
on a long-range exploratory mission
[Music]
send help
[Music]
with crash landed on an Uncharted
Celestial body
[Music]
I don't know where we are
I've located One Survivor
a child
the atmosphere is breathable
there's something alien out there
foreign
[Music]
you and I are gonna get home oh
finally ready
foreign
[Applause]
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing
there's already a superhero with a red
suit with a lightning bolt on it
it's literally huge and he's so manly
and Batman it's so cool and I'm just me
foreign
[Music]
to fight crime
okay
now everyone's kind of like doing their
own thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep it together
[Music]
you understand I'm a pediatrician
right
come on
[Music]
outfit of Your World depends on it
today
[Music]
[Music]
look I might not have as much experience
as you because I'm not super old like
you but I've seen all of the Fast and
Furious movies Lady it's all about
family
guys that was a signal
down
[Music]
the world will not survive this
I don't know how we fight powers like
this
I think I know how to fix this dude but
I really don't really everyone can be
worthy
now go fight for your family go fight
for the world
I just threw a truck and a dragon I love
my life
[Music]
[Music]
I can hear you being quiet mom
I am
hope I didn't ice your game man
no one my age says those words in that
order
it's just hard to see my little man not
be my little boy all the time
yeah
for years I've been taking care of this
little boy
making sure he is loved
that he feels like he belongs wherever
he wants to be
he wants to go out into the world and do
great big things
not bad kid
and what I worry about most
I love you miles
Davis they won't look out for you like
us
files
wanna get out of here
wherever you go from here you have to
promise to take care of that little boy
for me
so he never forgets where he came from
[Music]
and
he never doubts that he is loved
and he never lets anyone
tell him that he doesn't belong there
you gotta promise miles
I promise
[Music]
we are supposed to be the good guys we
are
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wish I could be
part of that world
[Music]
[Music]
we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrify us
they won't fear it
until they understand it
and they won't understand it
until they've used it
foreign
will take you only so far
I don't know if we can be trusted
with such a weapon
but we have no choice
[Music]
but what's Happening Here
foreign
since the first little girl ever existed
there have been dolls
but the dolls were always and forever
baby dolls
until
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
the last seven years of my life
living out my wildest dreams
Bianca
Rocky my dad
this is built on their shoulders
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
how long were you locked up 18 Years bro
just got out last week
cause I know you back out I know I've
been away a long time to get myself in
shape I still got gas in the tank come
by the gym
thank you
[Music]
guys what happened with you two oh you
can tell you he was like brothers
I was the best though but I never got a
chance to prove that that's cute
I know what you doing Donnie you don't
always do nothing
Damien's fighting the world he's trying
to hurt people I vouch for you you think
you mad try spending half your life in
the cell
why did somebody else live your life
I'm coming for everything you
threatening me
something is going on with you
Amy was like family
[Music]
now we passed talking then maybe you
just have to find out
I recognize mine I know that they needed
me yet
I need you to make all your fear
they're called a guilt
let go of whatever was and walk into
what is
[Music]
what did you want before Miami
I just wanted to escape my life
[Music]
do you like bartender it's not really
what I do what is it that you really
really
you came along and gave me these
unexpected
magical moment
that made me remember who I really was
[Music]
why are you in London I'm gonna put on a
show at this famous theater
disconnected they're gonna wake them up
with a wave of passion they've never
felt before hell yeah without further
Ado I give you the Visionary artists
magic mine
like
so we're so sure about it's the same
more will she marry For Love or Money
what does she pick
Ed the real question is why does she
feel like she has to choose it sounds to
me she just needs to let go
[Music]
good
maybe that as well
you're not shutting me down not this
time you're so good at this I'm not
gonna just let us give up on it I want
every woman that walks into this theater
to feel that a woman can have whatever
she wants whatever she wants
[Music]
right is your arrest her what's your
name Kim
lets you out for the warning right
foreign
[Music]
and where she go I'll never know
sorry
I'm Wade I'm Amber
[Music]
[Music]
we need to get you out of here it's the
night before you're waiting and you
can't spend the night together
bad luck we're grown adults we're fine
no actually you should go it's tradition
see she gets it I just want to ask is
that genetics or is it like Pilates
strands in your eyes they color them
wonderful we got you a gift it's just
something borrowed brings you good luck
except for Uncle Greg who ended up
decapitated on that forklift but that's
not the knives fault someone just left
it in the bathroom
look at you I think the left Booth is
slightly lower than the right boom
[Music]
something doesn't feel right
[Applause]
everybody asked it's normal to feel
scared remember anything happen to your
family I'm also feeling
in the mess
[Music]
we're gonna face
nobody with my family
[Music]
your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife
[Music]
I designed Megan to protect Katie from
feeling lonely
she will recognize you as her primary
user and when you do that you're gonna
pair with her
crazy it's insane right
Megan your goal is to protect Katie from
harm both physical and emotional
[Music]
I won't let anything harm you I love her
like it's not a person for you you don't
get to say that
[Music]
very good
what are you doing couldn't sleep
occupational hazard
the hell is that
[Music]
you should probably run
don't let anything harm you ever again
I can have I done something to upset you
Gemma I know you think you're maximizing
your objective function oh really
like
it's personal
laughs
Megan baby doll skill don't be Focus or
we will go
[Music]
you'd have to shut her down Jesus Christ
I thought we were friends
[Music]
I have a new primary user now me
[Music]
did Macon do something bad
what's going on
[Music]
what are you I'm Megan
most of my movies have been a reflection
of things that happened to me
but in the sense of the fablements it
wasn't about metaphor it was about
memory
sorry I'm late I picked up Mrs fableman
where should I put her up
[Music]
do not cry
and I will sing a lullaby
what kind of mood
foreign
[Music]
what's up with
I don't want to disappoint you you do
what your heart says you have to because
you don't know anyone in your life
the Fatal men's rated PG-13 in theaters
and at home now
in days of Legend gods
walk the earth
[Music]
say it what have I told you
Athena had returned in human form
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
I'd say your therapist is more this
paycheck
[Music]
[Music]
oh
yeah
medic
Jesus
Beth we should go
millions of dollars worth of cocaine
fell from the sky this morning in
Knoxville Tennessee there's more this
out there they dumped it somewhere I'm
looking for my daughter's first is a
dangerous place hey Henry check it out
something got into it a deer Maybe
a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to
go and get it
no don't eat that don't eat that let's
see what kind of effect that has
[Music]
[Music]
bear did cocaine
there was a bear a bear it was far hey
that's inappropriate
you're safe Bears can't climb trees of
course they can
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with a man forever
apex predator
high on cocaine
thought of it's mine
[Music]
oh man you [ __ ] it
[Music]
we have such good luck in nature
remember Marcus Markovich you gotta make
that
well he got fired
oh that wasn't nice nothing but bad news
for the Iowa is what an idiot
Mr Markovich I will offer you community
service coaching adults with
intellectual disabilities your honor
we're talking really no boo-boo words
okay fellas we're gonna do a simple ball
handling exercise my girlfriend loves
this
you don't have to turn them into the
Lakers they just need to feel like a
team
uh we're gonna need some help you're
getting a player off the injured list
welcome to the team cosentina what's
with the boogie board you do you I do me
okay where do you got this guy he just
showed up one day
this is my sister Alex don't do a couple
karaoke with us
get up and Never Gonna Keep Me Down
we gain better than anybody we got a
defense over here you got to learn to
build relationships I'm new to all this
yeah you can tell hey we got next Don't
make me say it make you say what
that's a boo-boo word we got next coach
this doesn't feel right
I should be coaching in the NBA well you
never know where things could lead
No Doubt
you can get this team to this Special
Olympics finals
might be ready to be back in the NBA
we've been following your incredible
story coach Marcus has just one win away
from qualifying for the regional
tournament
I don't know if you're brave or crazy
I know this is your shot at being
champions
thank you
girlfriend problems that was fun you
were passable I don't have a girlfriend
make sense oh what am I that bad looking
you know McConaughey
shoes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
why are you here
suppose I'm here to make friends with
you and your Dad's too
but my heart is broken why is it broken
because of what I have to do today
[Music]
you see the four of us have a very
important job to do
in fact it might be the most important
job
the history of the world
we were called
and are united by a common vision
which has now become a command
that we cannot ignore
[Music]
the four of us are here
to prevent the Apocalypse
your family hasn't chosen to make a
horrible decision
that he fell to choose
the world went
Siri called June Mom this is FaceTime oh
gosh I need you to write a couple of
things down the car keys I just said
write it down you're not writing it down
Kevin and I are headed to LAX and we
need you to pick us up on Monday keep
your location on the entire time I'm
away no fun got it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
hi this is Grace Allen please leave a
message
Mom where are you guys
what is your emergency my mom never came
home from her trip I don't know where
she is I'm calling about a guest you had
um does anyone speak English
this is selection Park please I need
your help the FBI doesn't have
jurisdiction to investigate in Colombia
so is there anything I can do the best
thing you can do to help us is just wait
by your phone
hi June bug I'm not giving up on my mom
who says and you go to this hotel and
ask for their security footage
says she sees two American tourists
what did he buy just this you think he
did something to her you're going
through Kevin's email you need to let
the police handle this I tried but we're
running out of time who are these
this woman calls him Darren
hey we're gonna tell me my mom was
dating a felon did you trust me on this
shocking new footage has leaked online
I have some questions regarding
something we're looking into has your
mom ever gone by any other names
what
the strangest case I've ever seen there
may be more than meets the eyes there
are some legit questions
it's actually a lot I want to talk with
you about oh my God
Final Approach to Target number one go
go
okay you got seven minutes stay focused
the art in here is worth millions
proceed to step two
what's happening
it won't open sorry man you're on your
own
foreign
number three
number three comment
help me get me out of here
got a Duncan Square Park
see do that for me
tell him I'm stuck here
[Applause]
nobody here but us pigeons
[Music]
I feel you brother I gotta set you free
when I was a kid My teacher asked me
what I would say from my house if it
were on fire
I answered a Sketchbook my AC DC albums
ground chuck I didn't mention my parents
were my sister
does that make me a bad person
cat died
music face
but Art
Is For Keeps
[Music]
foreign
flight Commander how can I help you
fugitive extradition
[Music]
oh is he dangerous what did he do
homicide 15 years ago I don't want to
scare the rest of the passengers I'm
afraid you're stuck with this Captain
get him on board let's have a good
flight
we're cutting right through the top of
the storm
that's to keep everybody in their seats
no exceptions all right
purely
[Music]
mayday mayday mayday
we are dark
then we're done somewhere in the Jolo
Island cluster
it's run by separatists and militias the
Filipino Army won't even go there
anymore
the clock is ticking every minute
matters
we can count those minutes in lives lost
or saved
emergency I'm captain Brody Torrance
I like this guy
Maxwell Carver England country
[Music]
my passengers my responsibility
gonna need your help you're gonna need
this
form of militarism you can see that
why did they lock you up no one cares
what really happened but they say
redemption can be found in the most
unusual places
you'll probably never see your family
again
I have a daughter and it had every
intention of making a home
we are going to come at us with
everything they've got
we're getting off this island
[Applause]
[Applause]
I want you to understand
how good a woman your mama was
she took Colton Briggs the coldest
killer that I've ever met and she turned
him into a family man
my mama's dead now
they're another
tell me the names of the men who did
this as long as that little girl is
alive there's no room for vengeance
[Music]
you're protecting a killer
from another killer
can you teach me how to shoot
put your hands behind your back a break
especially
my father once you're done I'll blow her
brains all over this Valley
you ain't scared of nothing
Briggs decides he's coming
Grace is coming he's here sound like
he's the one who's scared
is my father still a good man
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
contractor you're possessing a unique
set of skills
[Music]
what's that
power nap you said it was clear I said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong anyway shall we
so what we got something rather nasty
has been still we have to stop that
getting onto the open markets who's the
buyer Greg Simmons the billionaire arms
dealer oh a lot very serious faces up
here in there you can't catch this fish
with conventional lures I'm sorry The
Lure being Danny Francesco
the movie star Greg Simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's the guy very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you I'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your sister
actually love my sister-in-law
you made that call Heaven
[Music]
no reason to be nervous they're all the
killers
you're an actor
okay I'm ready
let's go to work when someone pinch me
please is that Danny Francesca what's
next for you I'm playing a mysterious
self-made billionaire
describe me
shadow lady do whatever I do whatever I
do do whoever Greg was flying from was
amongst you last night
I can get inside the ukrainians I hope
you take them to dinner first before you
get inside of them
sexually
oh
they're gonna kill you now resume first
yes or yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
come on get your lazy ass up all right
all right above already that's what you
get staying out partying all night I'm a
promoter I'm working I got like 18 000
followers you know who got followers
Jesus take your rude ass to work you
just cursed what would Jesus say Jesus
will say shut the [ __ ] up this is my
house
you need to clean this place I ain't got
all day bro what the [ __ ]
oh that couch just fluffed itself whose
crib is this man Steve Jobs Steve Jobs
is dead fool I mean his house died
[Music]
dude got Miami [ __ ] Cleveland [ __ ] La
[ __ ] damn bigger city bro
oh my God we in LeBron's house LeBron
who James hey there go go you're a one
handsome [ __ ] he got a hologram
of himself just to give him compliments
you handled the decision to go to Miami
perfectly nah that's cap
I need 10 G's by next week I gotta pay
for my daughter's school they on
vacation how about we throw the party in
the King's house we gonna invite all the
celebrities we can make 10 times the
money we can send Destiny to preschool
College whatever tonight is our last
shot looks like we up out there
Hi I see you there how are you oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] I'm going to jail Kevin hi I'm
Peter is LeBron home
um by the way
black lives matter they do I posted two
squares on my Instagram respect
[Music]
I wouldn't do something like this unless
I was desperate
cracking bro
is
[Music]
[ __ ] we don't [ __ ] up the koala
you good what the [ __ ]
the [ __ ] your hairline is perfect anyone
who says otherwise it's just jealous
this guy
hey
how you doing Carlow parking
parallel The Watch
see now that you're gone
[Music]
I brought you some food okay bye are you
always this unfriendly I am not
unfriendly okay you're like a warm
cuddle
what is that looks like it's yours
nowado you're not taking over my bed
you think you have to do everything on
your own but no one can we can't stand
watching One idiot try to teach another
how to drive it's lesson time
clutch in and break break the car is
stopped I almost hit the car Mr Ryan's a
hybrid my life was black and white she's
always going to be with you
my father used to smile like that
exactly
I have a cat
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this video
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
so for my birthday we're going up north
for a week you're gonna come right yeah
it's gonna be fine
yeah it just came up just
just came up remember this thing I told
you about that sales thing turns out now
they do need me to go right
just I came up I guess what am I gonna
do without you my beautiful cow
we are so glad that you came
[Music]
oh we just really want you to relax
relax in what way
hey baby is everything okay
going on so I think I'm gonna have to
leave early when did he become more
important to you than us
[Music]
he lied to him he has every right to be
angry lied about what about being here
that's my girl
you're coming
I'm sure Alice will explain it on later
are you sorry for what you did how are
we supposed to be happy together if we
can't trust each other
how did Simon know you were here looked
at my email I hate about the girl who
went missing pretty worried about me
[Music]
go
that's what you think love is I don't
know how any of this is your business
Simon loves me I'm happy
[Music]
why did you lie to him I can't do
another thing wrong
well any person who knows you
I was darling
nobody loves you like I love you
my beautiful cow
welcome to Paris Joseph
Mr I fear this will not be a kind place
to such a boy
boy has talent but one in particular
that is exceptional very well
[Music]
I realized the more I sound the less I
was alone
you always so competitive
[Applause]
the show-off who spoiled Mozart's
concert May I play with you monsieur
I hope this won't be embarrassing for
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you are quite a remarkable man
I'm Marie Antoinette queen of France
hereby anoint you Chevalier any other
country man of your color would not be
wearing such fine clothes
Monday the whole world will know me and
of course the music will be spectacular
bold
you don't belong here you're a party
trick repet playing the violin that is
all
you know why it's the best
we're playing a dangerous game friend
you forget your place but break his
hands this world is painful for us my
son but there is always
foreign
you could be more influential than you
know leverage it
to take to the stage you will be erased
Filipino new front you cannot topple
what has been ordained by God
thank you
it's about you people
[Music]